Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In earlier episodes, we've seen plenty of
video footage about hair simulations and rendering.
And today we're going to look at a cool new
technique that produces self-shadowing effects
for hair and fur.
In this image pair, you can see this drastic
difference that shows how prominent this effect
is in the visual appearance of hair.
Just look at that.
Beautiful.
But computing such a thing is extremely costly.
Since we have a dense piece of geometry, for
instance, hundreds of thousands of hair strands,
we have to know how each one occludes the
other ones.
This would take hopelessly long to compute.
To even get a program that executes in a reasonable
amount of time, we clearly need to simplify
the problem further.
An earlier technique takes a few planes that
cut the hair volume into layers.
These planes are typically regularly spaced
outward from the light sources and it is much
easier to work with a handful of these volume
segments than with the full geometry.
The more planes we use, the more layers we
obtain, and the higher quality results we
can expect.
However, even if we can do this in real time,
we will produce unrealistic images when using
around 16 layers.
Well of course, we should then crank up the
number of layers some more!
If we do that, for instance by now using 128
layers, we can expect better quality results,
but we'll be able to process an image only
twice a second, which is far from competitive.
And even then, the final results still contain
layering artifacts and are not very close
to the ground truth.
There has to be a better way to do this.
And with this new technique called Deep Opacity
Maps, these layers are chosen more wisely,
and this way, we can achieve higher quality
results with only using 3 layers, and it runs
easily in real time.
It is also more memory efficient than previous
techniques.
The key idea is that if we look at the hair
from the light source's point of view, we
can record how far away different parts of
the geometry are from the light source.
Then, we can create the new layers further
and further away according to this shape.
This way, the layers are not planar anymore,
they adapt to the scene that we have at hand
and contain significantly more useful occlusion
information.
As you can see, this new technique blows all
previous methods away and is incredibly simple.
I have found an implementation from Philip
Rideout, the link to this is available in
the video description.
If you have found more, let me know and I'll
include your findings in the video description
for the fellow tinkerers out there.
The paper is ample in comparisons, make sure
to have a look at that too.
And sometimes I get some messages saying "Károly,
why do you bother covering papers from so
many years ago, it doesn't make any sense!".
And here you can see that part of the excitement
of Two Minute Papers is that the next episode
can be about absolutely anything.
The series has been mostly focusing on computer
graphics and machine learning papers, but
don't forget, that we also have an episode
on whether we're living in a simulation, or
the Dunning-Kruger effect and so much more.
I've put a link to both of them in the video
description for your enjoyment.
The other reason for covering older papers
is that a lot of people don't know about them
and if we can help just a tiny bit to make
sure these incredible works see more widespread
adoption, we've done our job well.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!